bonsoir je pense que dans mon travail ça
doit être la première fois que je parle
devant autant de femmes
c'est impressionnant donc je suis
correspondante en valais pour le temps
depuis quatre ans pour ceux qui
connaîtraient pas le temps c'est le
journal francophone nationale qui a le
sous titre médias suisses de référence
et puis pour ceux qui connaîtraient pas
le valais c'est donc à canton alès du
lac léman où le rhône prend sa source
c'est un canton il ya beaucoup de vignes
beaucoup de glace y ait beaucoup de
barrages et beaucoup de stations de ski
assez connus comme verbier ou
crans-montana par exemple donc durant
ses quatre années de journalisme j'ai
essayé de faire le plus donc être
possible
pourquoi moi parce que je pense que
j'aime pouvoir travailler sur un peu
plus long terme que juste l'actualité
parce que j'aime faire un travail précis
et factuels mais surtout parce qu'une
enquête c'est un peu comme une montagne
vous êtes face à ce défi vous savez pas
comment vous allez arriver en haut vous
savez pas si vous allez y arriver et
surtout vous savez pas quelle vue vous
aurez depuis le sommet donc c'est une
sorte d' aventure et je pense que ça
fait vraiment sens pour moi je me suis
souvent demandé quel était le sens de la
vie j'ai souvent pensé qu'il fallait le
chercher peut-être dans la philosophie
peut-être dans la religion
et puis finalement faute de réponse je
me suis dit que le sens de la vie
c'était celui qu'on lui choisissait et
que pour moi
l'être humain est un animal social qui
vit en groupe ce que je fais doit avoir
un sens pour le groupe et je pense
qu'une information de qualité une
information factuelle
elle est extrêmement utile à la
démocratie et au fonctionnement d'une
société
je vais donc vous parler d'une technique
d'investigation que j'ai abordé ces deux
derniers de ces deux dernières années
qui s'appelle le datajournalisme au
journalisme de données qui est assez peu
utilisées en suisse notamment parce
qu'on a pas beaucoup de bases de données
qui sont publiques et accessibles à tout
le monde et je pense que c'est un
terrain sur lequel ça peut être
intéressant de travailler dans les
années qui viennent
je vais donc commencer par un exemple ça
vous aide
z'ont que j'étais correspondant en
valais quand il ya un informateur qui
m'a contacté pour me dire qu une des
plus grandes caves donc un des plus
grands producteurs de vins du canton
avait fraudé le fisc étaient soupçonnés
d'avoir fraudé le fisc pour environ 10
millions de francs et puis la personne
qui était fiduciaire de cet encaveur
pendant les années de fraude
c'est l'actuel ministre des finances du
canton du valais donc ça pose évidemment
la question de la situation dans
laquelle ce ministre pouvait se trouver
la question du conflit d'intérêts dans
laquelle ils pouvaient être puisqu'il
avait travaillé pendant presque dix ans
pour un client qui avait fraudé le fisc
et qu'aujourd'hui il était censé faire
en sorte que les contribuables payent ce
qu'il devait à la collectivité
et puis immédiatement il ya eu aussi
beaucoup de gens qui ont eu des craintes
ils ont commencé à dire par exemple que
cet encaveur allait jamais rembourser
l'argent qui devait à la collectivité
qu'il allait jamais être jugé qu'ils
seraient jamais condamné pour les
fraudes dont il était soupçonné parce
que il avait des relations avec le monde
politique à un niveau assez haut placés
et pendant qu'il y en avait qui disait
ça il y avait d'autres gens pour dire
non c'est pas vrai la justice fonctionne
bien le canton fonctionne bien le fisc
aussi tout ça c'est des visions de
complot et de magouilles qui n'existe
pas et là je me suis dit que cette
question du réseau d' influence de
quelqu'un du réseau de relations du
réseau politique
c'était une question qui existe est
partout et qu' il fallait trouver une
manière de pouvoir en parler de pouvoir
décrire ces réseaux de pouvoir au moins
d'écrire un petit peu comment il
fonctionne et si il existe réellement ou
pas et pour ça il me fallait trouver un
moyen objectif de parler de ses réseaux
pour éviter qu'on me dise mais non tu as
trop d'imagination tu inventes des
choses qui n'existent pas et c est donc
je suis parti en vacances en turquie
je suis allé visiter la biennale d'art
contemporain de d'istanbul et toute une
partie de cette biennale était consacrée
à l'urbanisme l'urbanisme qui parfois
est un peu sauvage dans est un peu
brutal comme ça dans les villes turques
qui a généré beaucoup de manifestations
notamment à cette époque là les
manifestations de la place taksim et
puis il ya un artiste qui a décidé de
dessiner sur un grand panneau blanc le
réseau de financement de la biennale
d'istanbul
et puis il a donc dessiné patiemment
chaque entreprise ses participations et
les gens qui étaient derrière ces
entreprises et à la fin il s'est rendu
compte qu'en fait les financiers
généralement étaient des promoteurs
immobiliers ce qui pose évidemment
problème parce que le promoteur
immobilier a un intérêt à ce que
l'urbanisation se passe d'une certaine
manière plutôt que d'une autre
en voyant ça je me suis dit ah ça c'est
la bonne manière de représenter les
choses il faut pouvoir dessiner les
réseaux sur la base de quelque chose
d'objectif comme des liens financiers ou
des liens d'affaires en suisse il existe
une base de données publique qui
s'appelle le registre du commerce à
l'intérieur de laquelle vous voyez pas
les propriétaires des entreprises ses
secrets en suisse mais vous pouvez voir
tous les membres des conseils
d'administration et tous les réviseurs
de comptes des sociétés
donc je me suis dit je vais avec l'aide
d'un informaticien extraire ces
informations sur toutes les entreprises
de cet encaveur donc ça a donné ça vous
voyez en 1995 il crée sa première cave
et donc lui l'encaveur c'est dominic
giroux et puis à partir de 1999 on voit
apparaître tout de suite la fiduciaire
réviseurs de compte
alpo dit avec maurice tornay actuel
ministre en charge des finances
on voit aussi daniel porcelana qui
descend d'une famille qui est de la même
église que dominic giroux et puis
maurice chevrier qui à l'époque et
conseiller national et qui aujourd'hui
est chef de service à l'état du valais à
partir de 2003 on voit apparaître une
personnalité influente au niveau
national petter s qui est lui aussi
réviseurs de compte et qui a été ancien
président du conseil national et
candidat au conseil fédéral
et puis dès 2008 le réseau de
l'entreprise se complexifie puisque
l'encaveur créer toutes sortes
d'entreprises et on arrive avec ce
réseau à voir qu'il ya des gens qui
jouent un rôle prépondérant à
l'intérieur de la structure des
entreprises qui sont pas forcément des
hommes politiques mais qui sont des gens
importants dans la structure de
l'entreprise
donc cette expérimentation d'essayer
d'utiliser une base de données pour
décrire un réseau est plutôt concluante
parce qu'on voit que cet encaveur a
effectivement plusieurs rapports
politiques danser plusieurs
personnalités politiques dans ces
affaires évidemment cette méthode elle
peut être utilisé n'importe où elles
peuvent être utilisés n'importe où dans
le monde elle peut être utilisé
n'importe où en suisse et j'ai décidé de
l'appliquer pour essayer de comprendre
les relations entre les barrages et le
monde politique et cette relation là
aussi était et est intéressante parce
qu'en fait ça me demandait de
complexifier la méthode c'est à dire de
croiser deux bases de données j'ai
extrait la liste de tous les conseils
d'administration des sociétés
hydroélectrique ça m'a donné une liste
de personnes et j'ai croisé cette liste
avec la liste de tous les élus valaisans
ça m'a donné ça on voit donc il ya un
parti le pdc qui est sur représentée à
l'intérieur des barrages le poids
électoral du parti c'est 38% l'électorat
il à 55% à l'intérieur des barrages et
puis cette deuxième visualisation qui
permet de voir chaque chacune des
personnes qui siègent dans un barrage et
de voir à quel échelon de la démocratie
suisse et les active
donc là on voit un conseiller national
non quelqu'un qui est actif au niveau
fédéral on voit le président du pdc
suisse et dans la colonne de droite vous
pouvez voir tous les barrages dans
lesquels ils ont des sièges ça c'est
l'échelon cantonal donc tous les élus au
niveau du canton qui ont un pouvoir
décisionnel au niveau du canton
les anciens élus et à la fin les les
élus communaux c'était important de
faire cette recherche là parce que c'est
un domaine l'hydroélectricité pour
lequel il ya des gros enjeux économiques
pour le canton et notamment il ya des
grandes décisions qui doivent être
prises qui vont avoir une incidence pour
les 80 prochaines années on aurait pu
imaginer dans une démocratie idéale que
cette décision là elles allaient être
prises avec tous les partis politiques à
parts égales le problème c'est que en
ayant un parti qui est très représentée
dans un domaine économique comme celui
là il aura plus d'informations sur le
domaine économique
il aura une meilleure connaissance des
gens qui sont actifs du tissu industriel
de ses besoins de ces problèmes
financiers etc et donc il va être
forcément plus écouter ces propositions
vont avoir plus d'incidence que les
propositions d'un autre parti et donc
une fois que j'ai eu fini ses graphiques
pour réaliser mon article qui devait
paraître je suis allé avec ses
graphiques voir des gens des partis
minoritaires
je leur ai dit voilà ça c'est mon
graphique qu'est ce que vous en pensez
et à votre avis quelle est la
conséquence de ça et il ya eu beaucoup
de gens qui sont restés la bouche
ouverte en disant je savais que ce parti
était majoritaire dans les domaines de
l'hydroélectricité
mais je ne savais pas que c'était à ce
point là et je crois que c'est tout le
sens du journalisme d'investigation et
du travail avec des données c'est qu'il
ya beaucoup de choses qu'on sait mais on
les sait de manière un petit peu vague
on laissait un peu comme dans un
brouillard c'est quelque chose qu'on dit
peut-être au café c'est quelque chose
qu'on a entendues ou consent mais on les
a pas vus on les a pas palper on sait
pas quelle forme on ces réseaux on ne
sait pas à quelle jusqu à quel échelon
ils vont et on ne sait pas quelles sont
leurs conséquences et finalement la
morale de cette histoire c'est peut-être
que quand on essaye de gravir la
montagne
on a des chances de voir un petit peu le
brouillard se dissipe et et d'avoir une
vision plus précise des choses soient
empire soit en mieux merci beaucoup